I'm all hopped up on colors we're also
recording on the cameras it's on you all
you baby you're good all right here we
go
oh all right good San Francisco 49ers
fans cheer when their quarterback goes
down boo
r.i.p my sweet jana novotná you are a
true [ __ ] in but everything's gonna be
fine cuz Prince Harry and Megan monocle
got engaged sleep this is sports without
balls and then I insert some really fun
music oh my god sports without balls
fans friends family it's Aaron Foley
we're back in the booth at all things
comedy happy post-thanksgiving to my
right hostess with the mostess Trish
Suhr Thanksgiving and to my right the
very talented funny is how we've been
laughing so hard we forgot to hit record
Adam ran oh thanks so much guys happy
happy pre Passover I know a lot of
people aren't you went over to pass I'm
skipping Hanukah don't write this
ourselves okay that's fun of the the
Jewish holidays I could get skipped over
because it's it's around too much extra
festive days you know Passover kind of
lives by itself st. Patrick's Day is
around there but like considered more of
a boozy day and Passover I guess
Passover boozy for the Jews it's as
boozy as we get effect well Sean and no
one's getting too [ __ ] up I get I get
yeah just like day one date night too
have you ever gotten have you ever been
to a Passover where there's a lot of
marijuana and people are just making up
the the story of Passover
no I please invite me yep because I've
never been to a Jew I've been to one
Jewish wedding that was awesome but I've
never been to like a pass a seder is it
always called a seder if the the meal of
the big event after because you're
talking to two Catholics right
sir is it so you saying like from year
to year we could change the name of the
whole I don't know no no no like the
dinner after an event after because I've
been one time after Russia Sean forgive
me Russia's the one that's fasting
that's the Jewish New Year that's yeah
Yom Kippur don't Kippur Rosh Hashanah
the Jewish New Year I got invited to
break the fast yeah okay but they didn't
my girlfriend Jamieson bombed it and
tell me that's what it was called she
said hey do you want to come after we
have the holiday we have a big dinner
basically it's just time to eat yeah all
right and then I didn't realize it's
kind of like Thanksgiving issue
everybody got up and said something
positive and whatever said the rabbi
with their family friends point of the
story is they came around and asked me
and I wore my big-ass cross like I don't
know where I thought I was going and I
got up and said I'm so tickled y'all
invited me to time to 8:00 and you just
heard like silverware drop what she has
called me okay your version yeah the
food was killer by the way but her noon
Thanksgiving I've ever been to for real
yeah she was go big on the holidays big
I was thrilled this year with
Thanksgiving not because of the food and
company which is obviously number one
and number two well number one company
number two food for sure because the the
company can make the food better amen
yeah or worse but what happened this
past Thanksgiving because we have to I'm
gonna have to real everybody and for the
next four hours is the Cowboys lost to
the LA San Diego Chargers and it was it
was it was a gift that kept on giving
hours after the game I go remember when
the Cowboys lost in front of all of
their fans and everyone go
and then right after was Giants Redskins
and I was thrilled right Giants lost you
were two words say Quan Barclay I want
the first of the second pick
I want everybody fire are they tanking
it and Eli's gone no no like Eli is not
gone he's not gone you don't want them
to leave
no anyway um so you talk about my
parents divorce well we go the playoffs
a great defense if we don't win ma it's
Eli yeah it's all we know you always put
on the quarterback right in any
situation if there's no Peyton Manning
Eli Manning is respected if there's no
Archie Manning Eli Manning if there's no
Papa John Papa Murphy gets a lot of heat
yeah oh you're saying it goes in every
yeah it's quiet and it likes to antique
with his mom so everyone throws a minor
guess what I'll take Eli over Peyton any
day of the week any game of madden of
the week oh I think he'll eyes will go
down as a better quarterback I think
he's gonna get a resurgence wherever he
goes after New York rest in peace but I
think he's odd he's more fun to watch I
think Penn with you I think Peyton is so
boring and vanilla yeah look he's better
on SNL than Eli was I'll say that
without even blinking and I got all the
personality I don't know if I don't know
I think I think I think I would take I
think I might take that's that's a hard
one because I like them both but I think
I would feel if I you can have one
Manning gun to your head
Oh Eli but that's just like for company
I think though she's got that magic in
the in the playoffs in the Super Bowl
that this cuz I'm with Adam on this I
think Eli's just been in a rut and been
done dirty I think he's gonna go to a
new team let's just riddle me this I
know it's not your Johnson this is a
little bit of an aura i suffocate myself
with my own head would you still follow
him and love him if he could question
what's eyebrows I've got the NFL ticket
I could watch my Giants and I can watch
wherever my sweet boy Eli plays because
I do think he's gonna have a massive
comeback wherever he goes much like
Peyton like
he did his time he did his time with the
cults he left and went to Denver and
became baby Jesus
I think the same was gonna happen to Eli
now that you do bring up a great point
and I'm not gonna stray away from
football too hard here but just to
piggyback on the supporting a guy when
he leaves Kevin Durant I did not support
him when he left Seattle but he was only
there for a year and then left okay so
it was almost like you know your whole
team is not fresh so so I couldn't even
it's you know day for a year day for
eight years there you go yeah you know I
wish you the best
yeah you were around you'd give me a lot
of good times one year yeah you just
like gotta watch you [ __ ] everybody else
on national TV yeah
how about a few date for two it all
along she doesn't want a wife her I get
her committed relationship and now she's
in one okay hey you guys hey we're back
hey we're back you guys ah it segues
really good really good
um I'm gonna let's talk Adam you are all
think Seattle yeah baby and so well
here's here's how the podcast is gonna
shake down we got some NFL we're in the
throes we're in the throes of the NFL
week 13 I'm holding Seattle but I'm a
Trojan okay see during the peak Carol
basically you know that 34 30 the wall
that was I was there that time good well
now he's my pro coach so but you dub
universe Washington I mean I was then
before I was a I was when I was a
college football fan truly it was
University of Washington but then when
you go to a school when they're the
greatest
yeah maybe college team ever like
there's no way you can't and you dub one
the Apple Bowl sure hook up the Apple
caught it yeah it doesn't matter I
wanted though my ex my ex one did
Washington state so I know I do I
watched that for a couple years yeah and
yeah it's an intense rivalry no it's fun
I didn't know about it's fun you know
when you learn it like I was like how
cool it's like an Apple Cup yeah like I
loved everything about it and when they
go to Pullman and what for Washington
State those games are usually very cold
and snow it's like a true it's like a
Lambeau Field type environment so people
get also Pullman there's just not much
to do out there so they go they go they
wake up they drink yeah if there's no
football going on they just they drink
no football starts you know even if it's
like March I watch it on ESPN Classic
well we're gonna do some that's great
because we're gonna do some college
football this is this is the time of the
year where you Foley tackles literally
and figuratively I'm some more college
games and next Saturday is like the
mecca big day the games
it's like Sampras versus Agassi yeah all
day long I literally wrote down the
schedule because I started canceling
plans and I've got a 9:30 a 1 and 2 at
5:00 I'm not doing any you're not I'll
send you post mate and then we've got uh
we've got I've also started decided I'm
gonna write out the entire collegiate
women's volleyball bracket because it
was just announced women's collegiate
volleyball is so they are so good good
it's like it's like hi it's better live
yes I'm gonna go see see I didn't grow
up with volleyball volleyball and then
ironically the Kentucky Kentucky got
like a number like what they considered
a number one seed if it was like NC
double-a basket in the record so number
four it's insane
we didn't have it then I mean that's
half the reason they didn't have tennis
when I went that's why I played for
Arizona State so I was like it's very
joyful Kentucky didn't have tennis not
not in CIA it's Tom right is it just not
what's their deal with that basketball
basketball
did I mention we have basketball and
then we have basketball yeah and then
football and then basketball so if you
try to play tennis you just like you're
a weirdo there's like oh they're like
the ball against the garage cuz that's
your scholarship basically you're not
going here you're not going in this
state you can come it'd be fun it's a
club sport Oh bummer
yeah so that wouldn't gonna pay for my
yeah so yeah now they do have it and
volleyball I mean I don't think any of
us were tall enough and we didn't have
volleyball you got to play tennis I was
like you put two sawhorses up we didn't
even have volleyball proficiency in high
school oh these girls volleyball team an
underrated sport you know yes it's also
it's more setting than like UFC which I
feel like is has taken a real big turn
in the last five years you know as far
as popularity I think volleyball is next
you know volleyball hopefully
bobsledding hey how can you make a John
Candy movie about it and you can't get a
little bit more recognition I'm on that
team any day of the week some Jamaicans
in a bobsled we need it they need a
volleyball movie that's that's Cool
Runnings ask member blook remember
American and I love to me what's that
the gymnastics movie no it was in the
80s it was um oh she married yeah she
married Gretzky Janet Janet Jones
yes Jones and don't tell me don't tell
me
oh not Greg Louganis no Mitch Mitch gala
it's one of the greatest sportsmen oh
it's about the heat between those two Oh
also great but effect the next
gymnastics movie unfortunately is gonna
have to be about all that so it's I
haven't Adam we haven't even covered it
because I'm so disgusted that you are
all playing one of the coaches no bring
the doctor did he guilty he that makes
me so sick because like little worse
here's what's worse and we'll cover this
for two seconds because I want to choke
him out yeah here's what I feel like
though karmically oh yeah in the
hierarchy of prison he's gonna whatever
he's done it's coming back to you cuz
they you know they don't put up with
that in prison they actually have some
kind of number one oh yeah so if the
prisoners pedophilia pedis nerves will
will kill you pedophilia right are they
- they'll rape you then they'll kill you
yeah but those are the two like you know
one or that that everybody makes you
feel a little better right like it's
like doubly sick but given like what he
did like give them some of those
prisoners that are like doing that it's
like you're kind of a hero and pretty
its Batman you get a couple years
knocked off your sentence for doing that
we wished I would be okay if it was a
little bit more like Hunger Games and
you were like listen we appreciate some
people I can't start televising prison
you know it's right around the corner
taking those cameras and putting it on I
don't know locked up and miss NBC yes
but actually I could pax needs to get
back in the game packs oxygen lives on
their mission out without a late-night
show dude dude live prison well prison
like my present from pax like the people
that brought you those Kirk Cameron
movies that nobody watched with an
exclamation point my prison
oh my god and make it competition it's
like a reality show it's like Big
Brother meets yes prison yeah that's the
[ __ ] come on pax no it's just when you
said that like I know you're right but I
immediately was like oh god but that's
what you feel like because there's to me
there I mean there's I don't know I
don't want to go off on a tangent but
like 20 seconds there's I don't know can
you argue there's anything worse than
what he did it's like [ __ ] human what
ye know and what's what's worse there is
nothing worse other than if he actually
killed him like the only yeah are the
only padding a senior citizen like
helpless like children citizen at least
you had a good run
yeah these kids are eight nine years old
starting that yeah Oh anyway okay
anyways gonna I hope he gets his dick
chewed off whatever
now that volleyball movie what is
American is it okay that we have to do
that was gymnastics okay there needs to
be one and there needs to be I mean you
know whether it's a you know like you
know there's gotta be a miracle type
story he made volume but in the
volleyball will you know what I just
learned this cuz my niece she plays
volleyball and she's my size she's five
barely bumped to and I was like will you
play volleyball like I don't know
anything about it it's just trash I'm a
little bear oh and I was like nice why
are you saying it like I don't I got no
like she can walk onto the net and I was
like I understand what you do in
volleyball just I'm the Libero well I
didn't realize there's always some
little short thing on there yeah that
like digs and is under the net on
purpose and I thought God this so cool
so it needs to almost be from the
underdog libero you know it oh you need
to take a little bit of remember the
titans a little bit of coach carter a
little bit of Sandlot a little bit of
miracle little bit of Hoosiers Rudy take
put it all in a baby
Rudy sports movie soup sprinkle a little
bit of Rudy in there I gotta drop a
Denzel in stir it up yeah then that a
coach something this this could happen
you guys remember cars cry
yeah beach volleyball yeah so carts
cried coaches are our Olympic women's
volleyball yeah and you know let's say
let's say you know plotline
you make him like a big drunk you know
after his beach volleyball career just
kevin costner courage cry ask character
just goes into the dark and all he does
all day is rock back and forth and
watched him cop and called the lines and
quote beckon he goes man I'm go I was
anyway knowing the lines from place this
out laces a bar from another and then
he's just like laces out right yeah bike
you know and and so then you know this
team this women's team bands together
like the only need you and then you know
half the women seem like some of them
don't have likes and they're like okay
like there's like one the big hitters
got a fake leg yep and then karai gets
reinvigorated with these like killer
awesome female throw in a refugee and
they're from some country that came over
and doesn't even know about dodgeball
that's the little one that does all the
setting Barrow because she's like a
power tiny asian lady that can use la
vía Oh our first ten years spent in a
closet yeah oh that's like an Olympic
story right already and her and the one
with my nickname is lazy susans it was
the only show babe is there everyone's
like you called her lazy because all she
does is watch suddenly Susan and she
doesn't like the greatest set of all
time I'm telling you right now you guys
this is gonna be a volleyball is already
so intense live like when you shoot that
cinematically it just like yeah I mean
all you gotta do is put most shots on a
dolly have some cool zoom ins cut to the
scoreboard and the commentators are
gonna be so intense yes
it's gonna put volume on the map you
guys this is a great Rockwell probably
plays like love Sam Rockwell one of the
dads yeah I don't need always plays one
of the dads like that yeah you gotta
have the younger hipper like a Paul Rudd
who just accidentally like just totally
loves his daughter and has no idea what
the hell it is yeah it's totally into
his phone and then one of the girls
almost like Elena Delle Donne my
favorite one of my favorite WNBA players
she was like full ride to UConn yeah but
just just couldn't handle it she
couldn't be away from her family
so you've got one volleyball player that
had like you know a full ride to like
you know
Texas or Kentucky or Pepperdine and ferd
one of these top teams and then she goes
to this smaller college dude like Adam
banks and Mighty Ducks remember yes
Emilio stole him from the good squad I
was like you're a cake eater and I don't
I still know what that means I don't
either
it means like you're you're rich right
like you get you get cake
oh yeah ten bucks
[Music]
shitty nickname is the kid I saw
frosting i watch the lovely Susan this
is if anyone was driving during this
five minutes of it yeah if your mom is
suddenly Susan drinking game that's I
think it's been mentioned twice one more
and that's a bottle of patron down the
gullet post-thanksgiving I'm gonna help
everybody out Susan Susan all right here
we go
ah well we just nailed their volleyball
segment but seriously I always do this
like I say this every week every other
this is this is the time of the year
where we're gonna get lucky because the
Olympics starts soon we read by the way
a lot of female professionals is it
Pyongyang is that sorts happening again
South Korea have you seen the
commercials that look like a Mentos head
great okay I don't support of that
that's freaking me out
I was like I don't understand why
everybody's marching in the streets like
I'm gonna just I'm gonna pull it up you
guys okay it's going on our Facebook
page um no this is this is the time of
the year you know where we don't have a
lot of women's professional sports so I
go deep in collegiate but we'll get a
boost
coming soon because we've got all like
the skiing championships we've got all
winters awesome well it just even see
like oh my god the ice hockey I'm gonna
have to call in sick all of February as
women's ice hockey it's really I haven't
really paid attention to the winter love
beer so since 94 really I've watched in
in I just the Summer Olympics I just
loved so much because of basketball and
I just yeah there's the winner though
but I do love
but I watch it in so many broken up like
segments that I don't think I get a full
meal of all the sport I never know
everyone if any they schedule for the
lavake
it so it's gonna be I'm telling you
right now it doesn't matter who's
playing it will be they'll be somewhat
competitive but it's and then it'll be
Canada US for the gold medal Canada
always beats us but tune up this year we
beat them three out of four times so we
have a chance we almost won four years
ago they're professional women's hockey
there is I'd called it's a bunch of
failed leagues but this league might
stick right now there's five teams small
you know smaller venues it's it's it's
it's but it's privately funded cool yeah
it's like one's there's like a you know
a Boston team in New York team that
plays in Jersey I think they play in
Newark
who's the Wayne Gretzky of the woman's
hockey league what's her name oh I would
say Hillary night Hillary name and
Kessler who plays NHL his sister I think
it's Meghan Kessler she's amazing
there's a there's some and you know they
can't check so they have to stop on a
dime a zhing athlete check yeah there's
no checking say I have a big issue this
is good I'm this rabbit hold another
time Adam but I have an issue because I
think kids now are being raised co-ed
everything and we still put upon them
the male-female everything's separated
right yeah so I would love a lot of
sports that genuinely athletes should be
able to go to that next level but women
aren't gonna be afforded that just
basketball we have this argument lot in
basketball so I have the similar
argument in hockey meaning I think that
they have to need to start creating
battalions co-ed battalions to go out
and deal with things because I used to
poopoo the WNBA like nobody's business
Aaron had to sit through me I was like
just get rid of it it's a tax write-off
whoa well because I said this is
ridiculous that they're not putting that
kind of funding into these amazing
athletes it's silly yeah but when you
watch the fundamentals we went to a
Finals game
it was unbelievable w WM being these
women rock stars lights out I think some
of them could rock in the NBA for sure
but they should be battalions where they
come in and do the free throws the
fundamental they don't miss they don't
miss yeah and then it's
performance-based all of a sudden
your check matters in a whole different
way that's what I think needs to start
happening to these younger children they
don't care they play together up until
high school we're the ones that we mean
it you know I think the women's hockey
should get together and if they want to
check they should check if they don't
want to check they shouldn't check who I
don't know if they should check or not I
think it's up to them yeah you know
obviously it was done because violence
and you know or physicality and all that
stuff but when you when you when you
don't like if you watch women's soccer
right there's no one there's not there's
a quarter of the flopping in men's
soccer it's almost hard to watch because
of the flop you literally elbow you you
touch elbows the guy goes down doesn't
exist soccer is men soccer is so it's
like the WWE that might be the reason I
don't watch is the amount of flopping
women's isn't like that like you know
there are athletes it should be on the
athletes to decide it's almost like
recess when we used to play tackle
football in fourth fifth and sixth grade
like the research teacher wouldn't come
over me like are you guys are doing to
any touch today because I you know it
looks like Todd DC they grew a couple
inches over the summer yeah real kid's
name by the way yeah this kid by the way
was like my bully right so fat Adam from
fourth grade to sixth grade got teased a
lot
right and Todd DC that's all right I'm
fine now you're a handsome young man I
know you used to wear bum equipment
sweatshirts and he would make fun of me
so I would call him a bum which again my
creativity but it was written all over
the chest right but you're a bum Jeezy
right yeah like a dad in the stands like
you're a bum Jeezy are you wearing over
like large cat I was yeah I was working
Hammer pants and a jersey that was too
big for me to think average and so Todd
one day was just like I mean we were we
were all again we just decided we'd get
on the field we was like all right
tackle today or not like just deciding
for the recess depending on the Seattle
rain how muddy the feel was like yeah in
tackle today and he was just laying into
me like just with these I mean you know
not only tackling everybody just being a
total dick but but just really laying on
the insults that day and then I remember
I started I said something back to him
some about him being a bum and something
else and then he looked at me like
Fernan in the bowl and just [ __ ]
charged at me and all I did was kind of
do like a little like quick fat was
quick fat so it was like a little quick
a little like a little quick
Juke like I'm going like I'm gonna get
the pop-tart so I'm getting mac and
cheese you know and I did a little like
Jake and he ran right past me and
slipped in this like big pile of like my
god yeah and fell on his ass and got
covered had to get emergency clothes
remember though to get emergency clothes
and dude it was on it was straight out
of a Disney movie because when he
slipped and fell like like kids cheered
because he was such a dick
and it was shout - Todd DC I hope you're
still with us but if you're not dude
that's [ __ ] Karma but no he emergency
clothes were that was like emergency
clothes because there's always like a
purple turtleneck that's that smell it's
just weird barrack order always yeah
with a litter in their pockets they
didn't even clean out the pocket so you
put your hands and you're like oh chap I
just bought the top of a chapstick like
that mmm is my mother's pan you should
never have to ask if this is an M&M no
yo he's a piece of dentine in the back
pocket
it's the inside of my mother's purse I
love all those stories okay so let's
let's let's talk some NFL and it's been
an exciting year I have to say this is
everybody been one of the worst football
seasons it has it has the amount of
injuries injures but I think this is the
started maybe two years ago and it's
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse and I I have to say is it gonna
get is it just is this downfall of the
NFL look the Seahawks might have lost
kam chancellor and cliff April for good
for football might have awesome mm the
injuries are that bad oh yeah did a lot
of research today and just and some
extra listening of Seattle sports radio
and like man what a bummer
yeah it'll be their choice I think but
look maybe what's wrong with them Oh
Cam's neck and you just you know how
much you want to [ __ ] with your neck
when he just got he was probably gonna
get in a little payday in a couple years
but he just got one and I think he's
chilling he's a good run
cliff too but I think his is more he can
come back it'll be their choice but it
sounds like with Cam like the neck thing
like I mean what he neck the way he
plays do you like
give me a break that's legion of boom
right the end of the legion of boom
maybe in Shermans what knee ankle no
Achilles back he'll be back because he's
also just I mean he hadn't missed a game
he'd played through I love him I hear
they do no wrong right I'm he's amazing
thank you this backstory is people are
so quick to dismiss that because they're
just like look at this outspoken like
guy who turned a couple of you know
fired up catchphrases into it some
commercials and like dude you know it's
a family storage you know what he's
amazing anyone to Stanford his dad still
works as a garbage man he won't take
like handout I mean I'm sure boy wants a
bit Stanford no the best around and just
gets a shot like this and here's where I
think the see Alex will be fine and even
right now the fact that we're hanging in
there with a you know depleted secondary
it's like there's always we have this
next man up mentality which is where
we've got most of our guys like even cam
I think was a third round at least there
maybe second but like Sean was replacing
you know Trufant or whoever was before
him so you know yeah we're gonna be fine
but like a guy that becomes that big
those are rarities where a guy fills in
and has that type of a story and become
sim with Doug Baldwin you know but as
long as Pete's around I think we'll be
okay but I also think if you look at
like I watched the Saints Rams and the
Saints had know all they're starting
they're starting corners and like a
safety we're all out you know it's
almost like every team is decimated so
it's it's if you hang on to like some of
them you have a better chance but at
least it's not like oh my god two teams
are just out of it because like ever the
injuries on every team have been
substantially it depends upon the
position you know you can maybe get away
with some a corner or alignments up but
you can't get away with like Aaron
Rodgers or it's hung we played yeah and
I saw the second half of that game I was
like this week but the week before oh my
lord it was a shutout how much of these
injuries do you think Steelers this week
late for um no play for UCLA Hunley what
did he play for
[Music]
yeah you know yeah UCLA cuz I was like I
know his name I don't know how I know
his name UCLA he'll be fine
but I thought he played I thought he
played as well as anybody could be also
I love the fact that I was watching you
know how much I hate Big Ben I yeah but
I was cheering the only time in my life
I was shamed for the Steelers and Trish
don't hate me because I wanted more
confidence for the Steelers going into
the Patriots game Oh
the Patriots oh this is a hate Patriots
table no no Trish likes she has good
reason she's been a fan of her life ya
know like true fan yeah totally fine I
mean I just bought into what they do
from the get-go I've been there but you
got to do I've been there from blood so
I been there since Pete I have been I
have been then I'm fine with that this
is definitely not a bandwagon such a
nation let's do this since we're right
in let's do this segue Adam I have a
problem and sometimes I get an idea in
my head I'll show you a couple weeks ago
how that I like to call Aaron you ever
see maybe a beautiful man oh it's a
great mom okay when it comes to anything
football related
really most sports but specifically
football she goes down a rabbit hole
this is my rabbit hole a couple of weeks
ago this is me proving the point that
Eli Manning is gets unnatural like
unfairly [ __ ] on this is a quarterback
of every single team and then the
circles are inconsistency and poor
quarterback play the checks are average
and it's one third of the entire league
has a shitty quarterback the top these
are people that have been around the
longest and you know they win because
there's consistent quarterback play
Eli's of course on this list and then
the third is up-and-comers people on the
bubble just proving once again that Eli
is a jam I posted this on our social
media and people were applauding Aaron's
well I've got more attention to detail
and then she came in with by the way
attention to detail was the name of an
episode in season four of suddenly food
and drink six they're playing at home
that is a new
specificity this is this is this is this
is what I did I got I get sick of the
Patriots and I just was thinking listen
I'm not taking away from the Patriots
they're an amazing team amazing coach
obviously great great quarterback
everything's great you know cheating
asterix world and some other stuff have
it but ensure but but what I what I did
what annoys me they do they are the
shittiest division of all time got it
they got a freelance instantly but so I
decided starting with the last ten years
starting with 2007 I would add up the
win-loss records of the Jets pills
dolphins Patriots and then compare them
to the NFC East Giants Eagles Cowboys
and skins just to determine once again
how shitty they get basically six free
wins a year you know I know what makes
dad I mean look they are I think that
the Patriots go as Brady goes yeah
although I feel like if Garoppolo we're
not done with this okay Rob Lowe gown uh
you guys shouldn't trade them I know I
agree okay but jets 70 this is 160 games
over the last ten years and then I'll
give you the numbers and then the
winning percentages for sure the Jets
are 74 and 86 0.46 winning percentage
and in the last ten years they made the
playoffs three times yeah the Dolphins
are 71 and eighty nine point four four
winning percentages they've been in the
playoffs twice in the last ten years
lace is that then the bills are 66 and
94 for Jesus which is a point for one
winning percentages they've never been
in the playoffs that's since the Super
Bowl since the Super Bowl this is well
since this is to that since literally mm
mm Wow the Giants are 86 and seventy
four point five three the Eagles are 84
and seventy five point five three they
made the playoffs four times the Eagles
the Giants have won had been in the
class four times winning the Superbowl
twice the Cowboys are 92 and 68 with
0.75 rating they've been in the playoffs
five times and the skins are sixty eight
and nine
with 0.42 been in the playoffs three
times that's just really another
division I pulled out of my butt just
because I know the division because I'm
in it when I say I'm in it I am part of
the team the Patriots are 126 and 34
with 0.78 it really it's division
dependent like you really are a product
of your environment the Patriots I mean
you guys they FC in general though like
I just I just want to say like I know
they're good but I have to say it X meet
at they play three consistently like
three of the shittiest teams in the last
at least 10 to 15 years yeah it bothers
me as a non Patriots fan yeah if you're
a Patriots fan obviously they still have
to win that's such a great team but it
just bothers me because the AFC is
shitty does Goodell make the schedule
who's making the schedule I would love
to do that I think it's actually off of
this is my guess I have no idea but I'm
guessing it's off of TVs and sales
because know what I'm saying like every
our division like playing Giants cowboys
consistently though 10 years is brutal
those deficient games are brutal and
maybe you'll get one free pass like
maybe the skins aren't good every year
this year they eat the Giants suck but
like you're still gonna get a
competitive game of the Giants you might
win but bills dolphins I'm just like
yeah the thing about it is now the the
the schedule this year and it's not the
Patriots you should go to a BCS setup I
I just think like every team should be
in the playoffs and you play one down
and the kicker has to and the kicker has
to be involved somehow like a won in
dinner but then yeah like almost spit
bone they're probably not the the move
to go with but I think there's a way to
like heighten mistakes for everybody I'd
love to see I'd love to see if the pages
are gonna have such a free ride I'd love
to see them not like it not be so free
once you get to the playoffs like
they're gonna have home-field advantage
sir and probably go to the Super Bowl
they FC sucks this year but like there
should be a chance we're a nail or a
team that is like I mean obviously the
Browns would not have anybody but like a
team that is maybe on the bubble or even
when I'm gonna make it gets a chance to
knock them out before they get to this
it would be cool right bracketology well
I mean you can see you
argue that that this set up you know by
adding the extra wild card game playoffs
no I mean I think the playoffs are are
well formatted it just it just feels
like just I guess I just got angry
because I'm like okay pencil and the
Patriots and it's just annoying debate
canceled in the Patriot baseball and
basketball or what both won that
baseball gets five game first on series
or was it cetera now for a first run
five seven I mean and those guys don't
bang their bodies around I guess as much
as football at all but you can't add any
more games to well know that out but I
think we can talk about it first of all
take the priest well I get rid of
preseason this is if you get rid of
preseason and don't have really
ridiculous injuries in preseason camp
guys really I mean what exactly I mean
they're already like you know lessening
the amount of contact in it's crazy I
mean I remember when I played high
school football the amount of like two
days and the first day I even played
football right seventh grade and I was
on a team this is a bike gabbar see team
that was full of ninth graders and my
self and more of my buddies in seventh
grade
we're just bigger dudes so they were
like oh you guys can play I was supposed
to go like five practices with no
contact I mean this coach just I mean
like chain like Rick or dawn or like an
[ __ ] Jerry well you know margin big
like starter Jack University of
Washington starter jacket that always
looks like he rubbed his cigarettes out
on the coat it looked like he got that
from emergency closed and the you're
gone adult you shouldn't be wearing
emergency clothes you're a football
coach and you're in your forties and he
would be a news item I was like I'm not
supposed to wear a pad yeah I'm supposed
to not practice and then you want to
pray you won't be a [ __ ] I was like
well do I mean I been playing their
whole lives yeah and there's a guy named
Jason Potts who was on the team who made
it you know just a [ __ ] you know
really just like you know as my mom
would say like not a very nice boy
and he would talk about how he's at home
got some big guys - yeah I was like -
Jason Potts you're a nightmare then he
was like angle tackling me and knocking
the wind out of me
seventh grade I remember the point of
the story was but so all the amount of
hitting it's way more in fact that I
mean like the fact that the pros but
then we would get banged up too and it
was just like yeah I mean but when we
started the season I remember we didn't
have a running back or one of our
receivers because like we were just
practicing so hard yeah and these guys
were getting [ __ ] up and it's like
just start the season just start just
start just be ready for it and do a
couple of calisthenics I do wish though
I mean the WNBA switched it this was I
think this is the second year they
switched it where the top eight teams
whatever the order is doesn't matter
Easter conference or Western Conference
that's how it plays awesome it was
really awesome because now if you look
at the NBA you think anyway and the Cavs
Warriors they'll be a little bit more
competition but yeah it's so boring but
if you you know you have you might have
a chance where the Spurs play the
Warriors or the Rockets play that's era
whatever in the finals that would be so
much more exciting to watch the fans
pick give us the power back do the top
eight doesn't matter what conference do
the top eight and NFL it doesn't matter
what conference why is it that easy it
should be that it should be that easy
there's just so much money involved
right but to me though I think it's just
it's been sentient it's been sitting
there ways for so yeah yeah and now
because it genuinely is about metrics
jersey sales TV time who does the
biggest ad sales well across the board
people are so we're so transient anymore
no one's from I mean my god half Hawaii
routes for Golden State I was like what
did I miss
do they really owe you go there much one
of the players from one of the islands
or no they just consider like basically
San Francisco and Vegas the extra - it's
like Andre Iguodala loves Jack Johnson
we play Jack Johnson - every beach bar
exactly exactly right they're like oh
they open with Bruno Mars Bruno Mars as
our people boom with it's the wall
there's a correlation between the why it
is interesting that no one is is from
from somewhere anymore their allegiance
to a team my god I'm from Kentucky Avril
proof the Patriots my whole life
so when not everyone the point is is
that not everyone's from that place so
why don't you just open it up I just
feel like it's antiquated thinking and
it's got a good here's here's a question
because I know like that's your also
your wheelhouse of like branding and I
live all that stuff but little Brandon
how much how much money does the NFL
lose if if you know you've got what is
it let's say it's six six right six from
the east six from the West
we'll just do tap twelve right you're
still gonna I don't think you're gonna
lose are you not losing money they're
gonna actually make money that's what
I'm saying they're never in the playoffs
old wat man you've got a bunch of old
white men that have probably never come
yeah never come to the game they have
never come of that either
well they might because you never know
they might wear women's shoes or
something fun you don't know who they
are but break my hair real quick but I
tend to think that when you have when
you allow just the next generation
there's more forward-thinking and less
linear meaning the only way you're
watching a game is on the TV it's like
no I
my girlfriend text me she was I can't
move your home not watching football on
Sunday because I was in Malibu all day I
was like girl if you don't think I'm
sitting here watching games on my phone
you're high with a backup battery I was
like there's no one here I literally had
a beach to myself watching football the
ocean heaven honey yeah I mean that's
but it's funny how people just have that
very linear thinking we can only watch
it on TV and I think that's the problem
with all professional sports if you
allow the access financially for people
to watch teams when they want open it up
to teams like we said like you get a
Hoosier story every year or the miracles
like it's something could happen every
year where you have a team you're like I
cannot believe it was the any given
Sunday and they took out the Patriots
one of the biggest headlines it would
rip across anything if that's we really
set sports up like that and you're but
you're not like in the NBA the argument
would be you know it's like you know
because the playoffs are seven months
long it's eight on each side it should
just be five games they should just be a
total like so I am cutting revenue there
yeah but I also think it would just be
so much better for the sport but you're
opening up revenue because more teams
are now viable so more people are going
to
Championship merchandise they aren't
though I'm saying if we do our version
no but what I'm saying is it our version
is is cutting a little bit I would cut
some teams from the NBA otherwise you'd
have to go one 16 1 to 16 and in
whatever order how they how they top
eight because they do top a eastern and
western and that's why it's seven
hundred months but we don't cut the
games I think we have to cut the amount
of games all the way around yeah games
well of course but what I'm saying is
like can we do this and still have the
same revenue and jerseys and all this
stuff I think you can it's just it's
just shuffling the order its shuffling
the order and okay if you want to keep
it you can still literally do the same
NBA and the same NFL play in it's just
in order of the record yeah so would be
new teams playing each other and not a
depleted AFC you know like the the the
the opening rounds to the AFC are gonna
be so they're chitti their shitty teams
this year there's been shitty teams for
a while so and now it's Western
Conference playoffs and NBA are so
exciting and Eastern Conference's like
and white for the Celtic scabs and who's
gonna win in seven is Gordon Hayward
gonna get back there we can do it again
well maybe with OKC - it'll be a little
I mean a hair Marc's not by much I mean
let's look at things like NBA Jam the
video games so good like you have a he's
on fire thing you have a what does that
mean I don't know when you when you get
when you score a certain amount of
points in a row and the other team
hasn't like you get this basketball it's
like a fire ball for Super Mario I would
have well anytime you shoot it from
anywhere it's going in right rock and
jock had like the 50 point ball or the
30 point basket I'm not saying we need
to implement that stuff what I think
should be on fire no but there's I think
there are ways to even like just make it
more interactive like the same way that
there's you know the way even like with
podcasts where you have like a comments
board and people are reading things
where people can call in for radio shows
like there's got to be a way for fans to
not make more like a video game but but
just give more just to balance it out
like if there's a way like midseason
where it's like Tom Brady might get
traded to another team for like three
game
and you guys are look at me like I'm fun
but I feel like that's probably the bad
example but just something that like
yeah that also makes it more exciting
and also were you every week you don't
know what's going on because the analyst
you can tell - they're just so trying so
hard to like regurgitate or at least
when something happens to focus on that
but it's like they know what's up like
they know that right now who it probably
is going to be an injuries I guess
always is what makes everything a little
but now with more and more injuries like
we do pics right and people play fantasy
picks whatever and I've been you know
watching since I was a little kid the
the parody let's say like let's just say
ten years ago five six years ago well
there was some great parody yeah and and
and you'd be you'd be making picks and
you go well that's a good game that's a
good game I mean every week we do picks
and I've been doing it for last couple
years and you go oh alright Wendy I'll
watch that one I mean I was I was in and
out watching games yesterday and there
was to me three or four watchable games
three or four watchable games yeah you
know like I wanted to see the Eagles cuz
I wanted to see how good they were cuz I
haven't seen them most of the year I've
seen him like in and out so I watched
the first half of that game was a
blowout they'd look great I turned it
off great celebrations the best
celebrate some of the best celebrations
I can't stand how much I like this
Eagles - yeah makes me that's I'm saying
hey let's bounce it out like maybe yeah
postgame interviews you throw in like
like a Daily Double type jeopardy
situation where it's like there's gonna
be one question that like you have to
recognize it's gonna be a little off but
there's a lot at stake where it's like
Carson Lee you guys really would you
have thrown the ball really well and
they're like what's wrong with your
voice man I'm just trying you know and
is that Ross from friends and and he's I
asked these questions you know you
through bow you know of yo you feeling
like luck and then like in the middle of
those questions you like hey can you
recite all the lyrics to Brian McKnight
back at one and if he can't they go
you're traded tomorrow for two games you
gotta go play for the Browns and now see
what happens to the Eagles again I'm
spitballing here
I literally just phoned a friend and we
just green let the green let this
program like mid press conference but
the Eagles are
so dominant and I feel like they're also
when their celebrations are that good
too
they're fun to war like oh these guys
are like so on another level because
they're jealous they have time to put
like yeah that's and that's every year
there's that in any sport right worth
game just can we also healthy there's no
healthy rid of the all-star games for
every team because they don't matter if
a madness fans can play in the all-star
game I am against it if I can if I can
play in the all-star kitchen the
celebrity softball squads yes and
putting them in the bad all the Network
Stars you could put your favorite TV
show people in also if you're worried
about being injured in season and you
don't want to do the celebrity find it
just give me the person that just
retired last I'll play with someone
that's 80 that I loved when I was a
little kid I don't care now is battle of
the Network Stars is that like are they
the true
they tried to bring back know ABC tried
to bring back bad all the Network Stars
the commercial came on it was my
favorite show when I was little really I
grew up in Kentucky nobody was around we
grew up with the fall guys six million
dollar man I'm majors from my hometown
he's from my hometown which is a massive
deal cuz we're from the middle of
nowhere
well he majors is also a big deal he was
a big deal right so he would come on for
fall guy him and Heather Locklear out
there honey running a red light he loved
you oh my god it was the most amazing
thing and then TJ Hooker Oh Gigi
Adrienne's a marionette so it was real
stars on real stars that were on real
shows at that time
ABC brings it back who was the first
star they show who Joey Lawrence fine
with that then and the do Erik Estrada
Erica friggin strata who was great and
chips he was I'm sorry I I thought you
meant the the one I was saying it was a
celebrity softball game where it's like
your dream fan when you're like playing
being against these I would yeah but but
not just some people like the all like
them know whatever it's supported it
like Ninja Warrior make make it a you
know yeah make it more fun
we are already what's new quick pics
yeah Adam the second team that she says
is home okay and then we need to talk oh
yeah then we got a we got a shuffle into
college and then we have to discuss how
much I can't stand Derrick Rose
anyway oh no gosh okay here we got week
real week 13 a quick impression of
Derrick Rose what's the definition of
consent he literally said that anyway
okay oh really
total pic Oh bummer I just mean you
couldn't stand his like hey man pick a
way to live well cover him in a hollow
wheezing always a mess oh no
and I said define consent yeah scrubs
uh-huh dude what when he yeah brought
over like a gangbang for his girlfriend
I think we covered it yeah [ __ ]
Derrick is that is that just a name he
hung out with Todd Gracie yeah Todd DC
clothes she was greasy though in his
emergency clothes [ __ ]
by the way broke quick Adam ninety and
seventy Seahawks 0.56 yeah baby it's
very good thank you in the numbers with
Aaron following week thirteen NFL
Thursday night game Redskins at Cowboys
okay so you can't over you can't
overthink cause it took us a half hour
dude you guys skins at Cowboys don't
skins Oh Thursday night I say Cowboys
come back and get right there ship and
they win mmm okay here we go Patriots
bills I love me some Steven Houska says
his wife and that's it I love me some
Steven Houska a one-act by Steven house
his wife Marilyn house guys probably
Marilyn what is her name look it up
somebody
Charlotte is Charlotte Hauschka Carol
look it up Carol so I'm going I'm going
back I keep Patriots you know Gronk
somebody love no he's not fourteen I did
one roast with him and he text me back
once he's a buddy that's wait I would
say he's about to talk about that cuz
Johnson told me about that when you were
when you were in complete makeup just
like a 75 Roya
they said we had to do that story oh my
god can you do that for two seconds
let's finish this I got some amazing
stories from I row so I'll set aside ten
minutes for that okay here we go know if
we have four minutes for that be back
can you do it in five minutes
I can cliff you could do it in two
minutes I give you
the suddenly Susan run down okay great
all right quick pic pics will do that
story okay and then we have to do
college football predictions 49ers at
bears who cares Bowl number eighteen I
don't
the Bears look terrible the 49ers at 49
49ers because Robson right enjoy Vikings
at Falcon that's a good game
that's a great game I'm taking the
Viking Oh Vikings difference Vulcans
offense is clicking I'm doing pure
home-field advantage over the Atlanta
nice advising ste though it's it's
reminiscent of my Seahawks 2013d that
that that exposed peyton manning's oh
face what do you call it heart pads on
case keenum wakes up the season teddy is
so bombed huh
technically I did everything to get back
on the Texans at Titans Titans who gives
a [ __ ] table for two I'm gonna go Titans
yeah I'm gonna piggyback on that I say
Texas okay okay Browns at chargers y'all
oh my god no one's gonna watch Chargers
well as Rebecca Lobo once said Browns
baby she said it just like that - really
are you pickin up a lot of people don't
do Lobo
yeah I'm picking the Browns just because
nobody will it's browns at who again
chargers oh [ __ ] I'm sorry let's go back
in time real quick Chargers baby it's a
real divided household Rebecca
mama Lobos lovely Rebecca Lobos got a
great a great and a story of how she met
her husband does she yeah was ripping
women's basketball she's like why don't
you come see a game he came to see a
game he's a sports writer fell in love
with her in the game oh my god where's
hey packs are you listening you got two
movies loaded two movies yeah
who's the sports that actually is a
great life
ABC family yeah I watched that dude ABC
family is the king I guess now free form
the king of holiday movies with toys
like that like you know that fun twist
where like didn't see that comment [ __ ]
on women's basketball
she was women's basketball yeah Mario
Lopez and Candace Cameron is Rebecca
Lobo in according Rebecca I'm probably
watching it twice he's so good and in
Spanish
I'll watch on ESPN Classic too and I'll
do I'll watch the 30 for 30 because they
better show the okay let's hit Johnson
writers Giants at Raiders okay I'm gonna
watch this and the Raiders will win I'd
say about by about eight to ten points
do you think Marshawn Lynch should go
back to Seattle and finish the season
yes
and although it'll never happen would it
he should and he should also Shawn right
now when weed becomes legal I it's good
he's gonna have his own strain odds are
good more popular than snoop yes yeah
because cuz he's an athlete just sits
around the house and that's fine and on
the package like the eyes are gonna be
like skittles
if skittles is real smart yeah smart
there's coffee ice cream
why not why can't the beef wheat I'm
breaking my own I'm gonna pick rule I'm
going Jew I'm going Giants what
yeah just cuz you know all right all
right
how about Eagles at Seahawks oh well no
I mean Steelers Patriots Steelers
Patriots but this is a second serious
pate is also this week yes you know I
think that's bigger than this game I do
this has NFC Championship implications
well Steelers Patriots says AFC
Championship Invitational
but but Patriots are one stealer - oh
they're bigger in my heart I will be
watching both games I'll tell you what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna say Giants cuz I love you yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna pick the Seahawks to
defend their home turf I think it's
really hard I think they're gonna get
they're gonna get to the Eagles I'm
literally lying through my teeth oh I
think 12th man shows up
I think Seattle literally like that will
affect like I think there's no way game
yeah where the fans recognize like oh if
we don't bring it yeah close and I do
think the Seahawks could win but I'm
gonna throw the Eagles but I'll tell you
this much I will watch every minute of
that game and I will watch the Steelers
Patriots and if the Patriots start
winning I will turn it off I love that
okay that was said so do you think
Russell Wilson is MVP do you think this
is him and Wentz go and going toe-to-toe
for the I mean look if if we advise
right listen is not an MVP we beat the
Redskins in the Falcons and those are
both has come back wins and then we
aware what were nine and two you don't
think he's in the conversation no I mean
he's in the conversation for like fourth
no behind who Wentz and Brady Brady and
went sprints and Brady how many times
can you win it Brady like that's why
give it all that's a given like Ellen
another and when you play that bills
twice in the door yeah and the Jets
twice you rack up the [ __ ] number
I think we're gonna win against Eagles I
think because I think I don't say the
season look the season was on the line
this past Sunday I think the division is
still up for grabs and I think if we get
that then we have a legitimate shot to
make some noise in the playoffs I don't
want all of our past the Superbowl have
been through CenturyLink and so the fact
that we now don't have an opportunity to
do that unless Carson Wentz goes down
and if if all the teams just get injured
like all the players it's like five
sinkholes all the other teams in the NFC
go into the ground and Russell Wilson's
like hey I'm above-ground they might
they might win no but I think this is
how your home field advantage claim is
accurate and I think also it's a Mike
Davis is coming back and Chris Carson
might be back soon - which gives us
those were two rookies running backs
that were dope and then got injured in
classic Seattle sports fashion and if
they're back I think I think we pulled
out Jimmy Behrens playing lights out
yeah I'm target him more you know what
if those guys come back
their boss at Albert I was like even if
you get promoted to checker you're still
gonna be like [ __ ] I like I like I like
I honestly like they're there they're
one of my favorites they are yeah what
do you love about them um I love the
12th man I'm a huge Russell Wilson fan
you won't like Pete Carroll I like yoga
I like I like I like everything about it
I really do you do I'm a huge told me
that before I bought it
I really we are gonna fly through the
rest of these I live beside Seattle okay
here we go here we go here we go
Chiefs it Jets Jets Smith on my face
Alex makeups benched Mahorn losing they
beat the Jets none of that's gonna have
okay I'm going Jets
oh you should falling apart
Kansas City dude hold on to that
barbecue in George Brett's Jersey Oh for
that cuz that's all you got
I literally was like I thought the
Chiefs would do the same thing they'd go
11 and four and then choke they're gonna
go they did it early this show all right
Andy Reid's such a good guy - I can't
Tom Selleck will play any reason easy
how do you read a good guy no I just you
know he looks like it's like well for
Bremen was Sunday well they're both in
jail did one of them died yeah oh no
yeah like two years ago that's a big
deal I need that coach like the next day
I was like what are you doing I don't
know maybe didn't that story's not
accurate at all but his son did Carroll
died
so I've you know immediately feel bad
for Broncos at Dolphins Broncos Broncos
at Dolphins yeah colors still out he's
also terrible I know but uh
okay Broncos that's horrible that it son
died I remember that now yeah Lions at
Ravens lions at Ravens Ravens I'm gonna
say lions I say Lance bucks at Packers
bucks
Packers bucks
with the old Ryan Fitzpatrick mustache
alert Colts at Jags the cold still an
NFL team for this week they are they're
going out P way after this
Andrew unlucky I what who are they
playing the Jags Jags are gonna have to
I'm gonna say Jags tanks are in a little
bit of a roll although I want Blake
bortles out because if he has to go
anywhere I'll go take him to Tom
Coughlin that was tags the Jags
I mean Dennis they lost to Dennis Quaid
and his 50 year old foot but I think
they're gonna come back would just quit
didn't Dennis Quaid he'll play that
kicker he played the remember the rookie
Dennis Quaid is the king of being like
I'm too old to play this sport but am I
will be right back in them in Dennis
Quaid in every sport that he couldn't
play that you thought he couldn't but he
did cuz he's Dennis quick it is quite
like Randy Quaid is also gonna be on the
sidelines being like that's my brother
home I guess that's my brother yeah why
wasn't he like the Clint Howard of all
the dead weight movies he was because he
he was that great in Days of Thunder
he was so good you're so good
independence dad oh yeah no it's crazy
alright we're back we're back we're back
we've got Rams at Cardinals Rams I'm
taking Cardinals in the upset I also
need them to do that because the sort of
CX when they beat the Eagles will take
over the division I do ie Panthers at
sight oh that's gonna be big love the
way you said Saints I'm gonna do them
based on that they do things at home
that guy chimera like Camaro but with an
A yeah oh god he was fun to watch third
round pick out of Tennessee what were
the Giants looking at wait nobody
they were looking at Papa John's
commercial oh the Steelers are playing
the Bengals this week Alvin Camaro
Steelers baby oh they're there in two
weeks the Patriots
oh sorry Steelers Bengals Steelers
Bengal Steelers
yeah is an adult never gonna ever gonna
have a is any Dalton like he's done I
actually you know what Omer I think
Annie Dalton on Ryan Leaf bust worthy
but that's like a that's a bummer Tim
now even remotely cuz he had a fight we
had a couple grade I think there's
there's there's I think if if you fire
everybody yeah right
you keep Dalton you keep tall and you
get someone like a Sean McVeigh story
from Chargers yeah and you get someone
that can figure him out he he could have
a great couple years in front of him I
still believe in Andy Dalton I still
wish somebody would just right the ship
of Johnny Manziel because that kid was
so talented yeah I just wish somebody'd
shake the [ __ ] out of him now that movie
I'd watch dude Todd DC as Johnny Manziel
and Menzel star in in and I'm not a bum
yara bomb sponsored by bum equipment
sweatshirts
oh that's it Steelers play Monday Night
Football bomb equipment was like FUBU
for white kids you know that's exactly
my god exactly what it was alright let's
just let's at least do college football
picks let's just do college football
picks if you're not a college football
fan or you're on the bubble the games
next week they're all the the conference
championship games but I don't think you
know listen I don't have a huge vast
knowledge of college football but I have
to say since we last couple years going
to the four-team playoff which is made
college football's so much more bearable
and exciting and fair every single game
every single game next week matters huge
implications like basically the only
thing you could say is the top four
right now Clemson number one Oklahoma
number two Wisconsin three Auburn for
right now listen we've record on Mondays
and the official list comes out tomorrow
but that's about 98 percent yeah that's
real close
you know maybe Alabama v Georgia six
Ohio State seven giver
take whatever but the games are as
follows for SE championship Georgia
plays Auburn what you could both say
when you're in yeah yes
Ohio State plays Wisconsin who do you
choose I have to write these down oh I'm
just gonna go through him and then pick
okay well we could do that Georgia plays
Auburn for the SEC Championship
I love Erika Davis but I'm cheering for
Auburn I feel so terrible saying that I
know I felt like it's an Auburn they
played Stidham that the Baylor
quarterback that I love that transferred
I have no allegiance to Georgia but I
have to say this if Georgia wins I'll be
very happy for Erika I'm picking a burn
because they just are on fire yeah me
too yeah yeah okay I mean Ohio State
plays Wisconsin I couldn't be more I
couldn't be more all in times a hundred
million was behind was call me too
yep and if they win they're in badger is
my favorite type of food sandwich to get
at Lobos right okay you know what that
full circle read the room Adam Oklahoma
he's playing TCU for the big 12 I mean
listen TCO is no joke but I will be I
will be rooting for TCU I do not like
Oklahoma I can't well he's not playing
well he just got suspended for a couple
for one rep boy how great was that rep
though by the backup yeah Miami plays
Clemson for the ACC tournament I'm gonna
I'm gonna get stick with Clemson me too
here's what I'm assuming is you chose
TCU no no no I'm cheering I mean I'm
sharing for TCU but I'm picking Oklahoma
oh no I'm picking a burn Wisconsin
Oklahoma and Clemson because my aunt
Shirley's menu and USC play Stanford on
Friday yeah I'm picking UIC in that game
yeah the SE yeah for sure here's what's
crazy right you could argue this Clemson
when they're in Oklahoma when they're in
Wisconsin when they're in Auburn when
they're in yeah yep so the it
great going into a game of the fate is
in your own hands totally right but what
would be kind of fun since I don't have
really a horse in the game except for
Wisconsin all of them too if they all
yeah that's gonna be crazy because if
they lose what happens you've got
Clemson at 11 - they all lose Clemson
would be 11 in - Oklahoma would be 11
into Wisconsin would be 12 and one our
burn would be out a burn would be out
Georgia would be 12 and one Georgia
would be the only and in Georgia losses
are out but if Ohio State wins they're
11 and - oh [ __ ] then it's one baby rock
paper scissor and Alabama would be 11
and one that would be crazy
what happened I mean is there just a
what do you do draw me a hat there's a
mathematic problem I think Clemson I
think Clemson if they lose they're 11
and - I think they're still in strength
of schedule and I don't think you but
but the thing is if Miami wins they'll
be 11 and 1 and they love women so that
this is just fun it's fun it's fun to
predict listen if Alabama doesn't get in
I've already won my house down you sound
like half the south oh who is Miami
you're Miami Clemson pick Oh Clemson
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
interesting I love it the best time of
year for sports actually yeah yeah right
well going to baseball postseason is uh
there's nothing like it it's the best
for me it's March Madness March Madness
is I think the greatest single
tournament I agree but what about
Wimbledon the first round
all right listen we've got we're already
running late so let's let's let's do
this real quick yeah we've got a back on
the bus that has to be discussed and
then we'll just jump to feel-good moment
of the week and I got a couple clips
from the roast if you want me to play
them oh my god you said can you actually
make quick thing yeah cinema or play him
into the microphone your choice they're
short they're like 30 seconds one's 40
seconds I can we play him into the mic
yeah
can we play him into the mic Aaron will
you also send him Wednesday
code okay so quick backstory to that
right Josh will have asked me do the big
popular oast I'm like and anything I
meet my immediate reaction was like no
I'm not a roast comic but then I was
like no if it said I don't want to do it
and I have like trepidations and I'm
like I'm nervous because I'm not a roast
comic and that whatever then I should do
it and then just figure it out so I'm
like oh what if I do as a character and
I'm like bi K Yankees fan like cuz it's
roasting Big Papi and an Anthony Mackie
was on in bill burr and Gronkowski and
Dustin Pedroia and Sarah Tiana I was
like oh cool all do is the characters
like [ __ ] yeah he's like he's putting
together so yes that so like I'll be
like a young Freddie New York friend and
I'm like nobody's gonna like that guy
like I would hate that guy no one just
see jokes coming from like a [ __ ] pop
you know it's like well what if I go
like full makeup and just like an old
man so uh I'm the season of MADtv I did
this past year the woman who did makeup
on it did makeup on SNL for a while
she's like top of her game so is like
hey would you if I flew you out put you
up would you like make me up like
unrecognizable like a 70 year old man
and so I can do this row so it worked
out and we worked out our jokes tonight
before lap Boston Sarah Anthony Mackie
Bernie Josh and and burr you know and he
and I had like kind of like light
conversation to comedy clubs and even
back there he's just like so what do you
don't know why you're [ __ ] dressed up
like Babe Ruth or some [ __ ] and I'm like
no I'm going did this whole thing
whatever so then we do our jokes and and
and then the next day I get in for like
four hours of makeup and nobody knows
what I'm gonna look like I didn't even
know and unrecognizable I mean I'll send
you the pictures you can like whatever
but I'm down the lobby and we're all
waiting to walk over to the House of
Blues in Boston and Birds down there so
I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] with them and
just try to start trying to get in
character
so I go I go bill burr I go oh [ __ ] I go
big fan big fan thanks bite thanks I go
yeah I go yeah I got some notes for your
cartoon and he goes what I go ya know
pretty good for me like I don't know
some boys that guy like I also like like
some of those [ __ ] this is the
opening [ __ ] you do like I start some
notes and I start taking my phone and
goes buddy yes [ __ ] on time for the
[ __ ] he goes are you [ __ ] serious I
go oh yeah man I go you can't take some
critique I go a realize what a critique
belper oh you're a [ __ ] brick and he
goes no and they just took a step close
to me and goes buddy he was [ __ ] off and
then I look at my go bill and he goes
what and I go it's me Adam and he kind
of like does this like double take and
they just goes what the [ __ ] man and
from then on out he was like I mean we
chummed it up way more he like you know
roshun went really well and he just was
like and the makeup my hat jaws and like
the cheeks he couldn't tell was me and
he was just like so fascinated by it but
ya know we did the whole roast it was
great and I Pedroia I thought I was an
old man because I ripped on him for a
while and he was just like asking
joshy's like who the [ __ ] is his old
Mane's like he's really excited I
probably spent you know him and Gronk at
the most time on but he's one of the
clips I came over for this is I think my
being a Yankee fan
[Music]
[Applause]
let me give you another like you say
what you look like
[Applause]
correctly counting the number of girls
in the videos
[Applause]
maybe one more yeah in Boston hometown
hero
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
oh yeah yeah oh you know we have to see
we have cytosis wait so is it is Josh
was saying like it's never gonna air is
it Showtime
Nessun was supposed to air it and then
they backed out because well TMZ was so
stupid they like pulled a whole thing on
Gronk and and said like you know Broncos
after Jews blacks and Dominicans it's
like dude everybody did it was a roast
you know and and so Nessen and then
Showtime was maybe gonna buy it but they
all just like panics because it was too
vulgar I guess but like I mean that's
that's where I thought I have to see I
can't wait to see well well you're
cueing it I'll do it I'll go real quick
back on the bus and then we'll do
feel-good moments a week back on the bus
that is a segment where we put athletes
with horrible behavior or journalists or
writers or anybody back on the bus and
we sent him back to triple-a and this
week it was I don't have you've heard
this guy before I think at this point he
probably is is following the ball family
bus
Aqib Talib who is literally starts a
fight with everybody every week but he's
got a real pension for fighting and him
in crabtree michael crabtree of the
Oakland Raiders they started it last
year in all fairness Talib ripped
Michael Crabtree's necklaces off of them
that was aggressive and so a Crabtree
decides in the first four minutes of the
game on a play that was not thrown to
Crabtree to block Talib through the
field onto the sidelines and wrestle him
on the sideline so that was the first
play of it was like the second play of
the game these are two teams literally
vying for a playoff spot every game
meaning so much then the helmet comes
off they start swinging each other the
benches clear out it's a brawl they both
get thrown out of the game in the first
four minutes of the game way to suck it
on the field and off the field
back on the bus you idiots yeah you hate
you hate fights in in football I'll give
you a fight now and then but out in the
first four minutes when your team needs
Michael Crabtree and your team needs to
leave these are the stars of the team's
dumb it's it's dumb yeah it's also let's
do it in the last four minutes if you
want to if you want to write something
just be smart about it
oh god it's just another inside look at
how high their emotions and their
adrenaline is like yeah they probably
they're probably I'm usually like the
probably talking [ __ ] and it could be a
potential fight like every moment of the
game right you got to be a profession
yeah and talib also you just his
behavior is so bad most of the season it
had to have been building that's a core
this is the first time they face each
other since the necklace incident of
2000 oh well there you go I know but in
the first four minutes
Tadeo team ahead of your [ __ ] stupid
ego you know back on the bus did you see
that the shot of Marshawn Lynch walking
to leave off go to the locker room
through the Raider sideline I didn't see
you I got a new weed coming out soon
called beast mode skittles the intent
this is it back on the bus because we're
running at a time as it feel-good mode
of the week we end the show every week
with the feel-good moment the week
because well you know nuclear weapons
and Trump and all kinds of other stuff
and the ripping off of necklaces and
this one goes to Morgan heard
sixteen-year-old surprised world around
world all-around champion in gymnastics
kids so much and she couldn't have had
more weight on her shoulders at 50 like
I could bring I get upset if I had too
many chores at 15 and this job the
United States literally so she won the
World Championships all-around world
champ you got lost in six and this and
this gets you to the Olympics is out
with this I know well it's the it is
definitely the track right everybody
that when has been our the last six
years it has been the United States it's
one world awesome yes they've all gone
so she'll be she'll be reppin us in the
summer Berlin banks well we hope we hope
because the only for go now not five but
I kid with braces and glasses doing the
floor routine like that's never been
adopted from China at the age of three
and
story by a single by a single mom it but
she didn't have cable she couldn't watch
someone is it so I think that no this
story has every piece of heartwarming
element you every element she's talented
as [ __ ] it she's four or five and she
says no also okay so the quick other
backstory Regan Smith who's one of our
shining stars for the next Olympics
amazed she's her teammate and roommate
and she was 2017 national championship
alternate on the Rio Olympics heavy
favorite to win the all-around she hurts
her ankle right before the competition
warmups
and we always win like the u.s. is like
files Johnson Shannon Miller like you
know and so it was it was literally
America's only hope for an all-around
medal now rested on the four-foot
shoulders have heard who was competing
in her first World Championship and had
never won an individual titled at an
international meet Emmitt to add the
pressure of the US team had won the past
six World and Olympic all-around titles
and she said she hadn't really been this
consistent she did four events did so
consistent in every single event took
and took the title and then you know
listen it's a four page story written by
Elissa wrote Roenick who was a guest on
the show a couple years ago and she's a
contributing writer for he's been the
magazine she did such a good job but she
also was a huge Harry Potter fan
she likes to avoid I mean I mean also
that's got to be doing something for the
braces community not that like you can't
achieve anything if your teeth are round
and the glasses
I wore a glasses when I was little and
playing sports and it was like de morals
were the games were the goggles are
sporty cockles on a little errand Foley
I struggle with myself as my stop
laughing that's a great image and here's
heard I'll send you a picture no one is
born perfect I'll take a quick fat for
fully goggles how about sounds perfect
here's the coat of the week no one is
born perfect you will have imperfections
I hope more people see me and try to do
sports or gymnastics with glasses
nothing should stop you from doing
something you are passionate about
this is her that said that yes I'm your
mom's killing it her mom was ill and
left exactly
left being Dale hygienist and took a job
with discovery like Discover Card so
that she could stay home and like work
telecommute so that she could be with
her daughter and we're machine razor
when she's showing such a proclivity for
gymnastics I mean I know that's the kid
first and and now do you think she
whispers in but when she goes to bed
like oh I think she's just like a piano
stick the landing mommy's gonna lose the
house you know just like just throw away
stuff pressures that a light Twinkle
Twinkle and bedtime threats I know it's
[Music]
that was you know oh my god I cannot you
have to send a fax we composure look
like you look like an old Yankee fan
recognizable I mean I would not believe
that you show the okay I'll put on our
fan page and on our Instagram and then
I'm gonna take a that's the thing too is
they didn't put a I mean I wish I would
have thought this makeup artist other
ways yeah cuz people put I'll just get
like some more promo but if this is it
an air or whatever Zeppelin the building
maybe they looked me up because people
would make jokes about me but since they
look like me they didn't really have
much to work with and just like the
probably put it should have put a
picture of you up there yeah so that
they could you know yeah at the end at
the very end after you just really
killed everybody because if you look she
was an epic makeup was amazing
I don't name's Jen Aspen though she's
unbeliev yeah I mean look at the NAG I
mean she even told me to she said we
could even gone like more so like with
the eyes and stuff but that was you know
I mean that's trim way better than a
young Freddie if I was just like because
you have a little bit more respect for
an older to Yankee fan
Adam ray you are a goddamn pleasure oh
man so much thank you come back any time
and where can people find you and see
you and what are you up to and what are
you doing so I have a podcast called
about last night then I do with Brad
Williams thought you were talking about
like how this girl is 4 or 5 yeah
brightest for four okay so he will not
be in the Olympics because of his height
restrictions but love that dude love
that dude so funny about last night as
our podcast my tour dates at Adam rate
comedy calm when is this coming out
Thursday oh great I'll be in New York
City this week at Gotham comedy club
Friday Saturday and Sunday
I started at Gotham did you really yeah
in the original location on 21st Street
that's incredible yep pre-show six three
on Saturday bring three people and you
get six minutes kept in touch with
people I did not like I could tell me
what are your travel but Gotham Gotham
is greater Gotham everybody oh yeah so
Friday through Sunday and then all my
tour dates Adam recom EECOM a bunch up
there and then some TV stuff and movie
stuff but not till the spring social
media which Adam rate comedy on
Instagram and Twitter I'll link
everything right put it all and anytime
you do anything you'll let us know and
we'll link it and put it out and every
time I see you in the the the heat I
scream out I know a totally they still
play that on like effects and stuff
right
I have it permanently bought oh do you
really love that movie so my do oh it
makes me laugh so awesome I saw it in
the theater like losing my mind
yeah and plus I knew you were in it was
this across is it oh my god I mean it'll
be either both great my sandy my sweet
sounder Bulaga uh Trish Suhr what are
you up to well you know me
I'm go to Trish Suhr calm and at Trish
Suhr for everything go look up Trish
finder and brighter hair little tight I
am in time in time for two weeks and
then I'm at the Oh what is that comedy
club name whoops I am at just pick a
city wait hold on you go to Erin Kay
Foley dot-com hold on just give me one
second what is the can I have a pen
time timecode errand 122 35 I will be in
Glendale Arizona in two it's Thursday
the 14th 15th 16th and then I'll be
doing a special show in Phoenix an LGBT
fundraiser on Sunday the 17th all the
details are coming together I'll have
them on Aaron K Foley a calm and on
Facebook and on Twitter yeah in town for
two weeks and then in Glendale Arizona
and then I will be in Tampa for
Christmas with Mary and a quick report
from Mary and Dick Foley dad decided to
eat some oatmeal and it expired in 2014
he started laughing and then pushed it
on through and ate the oatmeal okay that
was our conversation this morning
wrapping it up with another feel-good
mode of the week my dad eating expired
oatmeal he said it was bold but I was
hungry
unrecognizable package because quote
your mother buys organic crab cakes on a
Delta Airlines flight a couple weeks ago
and got sick as a doll and I such a bold
move in my head I'm thinking who has
ever like managed such good crab cakes
oh we're Delta Airlines 33,000 miles
north of the planet cupcakes on a plane
is like sushi at the gas station
what yeah the old tuna sandwich and a
coca-cola at a gas station Adam right
you're an experienced traveler cookie
mousse I love crab cakes we got a chance
to sit in some first class and get the
towel and I was just like riding the
wave yeah I was like dude this is a
great day club in Tahoe and you want to
smoke some weed and you randomly knock
on someone's door and say hey I'd like
to party I was with Adam when that
happened after the door literally said
the words hey I'm not I'm a good guy
swear I'm not gonna do anything crazy I
just smelled the weed and our first show
got over I tried to get this all out
real quick I'm like and I hear him
looking through the peephole there's
like 12 of them they were there for a
wedding and they all they all came to
the last show and like the groom ended
up like you know like hooking up with
like one of the other groomsman like it
was they told us all that stuff during
the show
it's all
I hear the people being like there's a
guy out there he says he's not a cop I'm
like they're like I'm like I'm in the
community you know I'll give you guys
tickets and one of them goes tell him to
show you the tickets they open the door
and they look look at me I go see I'm
not crazy and they go and I look through
the people when I see them looking to me
so then I'm like I need to present
myself that says I'm not a bad guy and I
want free weed I don't know so I did
like the creepiest smile you could do
through people that's taking a DMV photo
is this I was like like I want weed in
Tahoe for free please don't use this
during the next day I go you did watch
you knock down watch yeah yeah that was
like day two my experience of that thank
you so much for coming on the show
you're the best
Trish you're the best sports without
balls fans friends family have the best
week of your life that is